ils lui sont merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france bonsoir alors le
couvre feu instauré depuis quelques
jours qu'est ce que vous pensez cette
mesure est ce qu'elle sera efficace
espérons qu'il sera efficace
en attendant elle est nécessaire on
atteint là un niveau épidémique qui est
grave qui est très sérieux que l'on
pouvait redouter de déjà depuis
plusieurs semaines mais il n'a pas été
impossible il n'a pas été possible
d'éviter qu'on parvienne justement à
cette situation qui reproduit un petit
peu celle que nous avons connue au mois
de mars et avril avec bien sûr des
différences puisque maintenant on
connaît mieux les mesures de protection
on sais mieux comment et quand on doit
hospitalisés les patients comment les
prendre en charge
quoi qu'il en soit on est dans une phase
épidémique sérieuses dont on ne peut pas
prédire quand elle s'arrêtera
on ne sait même pas encore si on est
arrivé au sommet de cette nouvelle
courbe
peut-être qu'elle va continuer
d'augmenter peut-être qu'on est déjà au
sommet on ne sait pas mais de quoi qu'il
en soit c'est une situation extrêmement
inquiétante dans la mesure où nous
sommes entrés dans la saison froide et
qu' il ya sûrement un facteur saisonnier
dans la propagation du sort ce que vous
deux et donc il ya d'autres aussi à
l'affection virales respiratoires comme
la grippe qui vont qui vont apparaître
au cours des mois qui viennent
donc on est dans une situation qui est
préoccupant très préoccupante et qui
explique tout à fait le la décision de
d'alert et de couvre feu alors justement
un conseil de défense aura lieu demain
est ce qu'on peut imaginer que le
couvre-feu concerne
d'autres villes est ce que de nouvelles
mesures pourront être prises ou devrait
être prise selon vous les décisions qui
s'appliquent pour le couvre-feu son sont
prises en fonction des indicateurs
indicateurs donc d'un taux d'incidence
dans la population en général taux
d'incidence et les personnes de plus de
65 ans et au niveau régional le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation
donc c'est en fonction de ces trois
indicateurs que se décide effectivement
le la mise en alerte et là et
éventuellement le confinement nocturne
type de couvre-feu donc il est possible
que cela s'étende à d'autres villes
d'autres grandes villes qui sont
actuellement touchés et on voit qu'il ya
plusieurs villes qui sont actuellement
en alerte maximale qui peuvent tout à
fait basculer dans cette situation c'est
difficile de le prédire mais c'est
envisageable c'est même assez probable
maintenant ce qui serait vraiment
catastrophique c'est que l'ensemble du
territoire ceux concernés et que l'eau
soit contraint de revenir à une
situation de confiance de confinement
général comme au mois de mars à bry
alors beaucoup font remarquer que si on
a de nombreux cas de contamination ces
derniers jours depuis le début de la
deuxième vague c'est par ce conte est
beaucoup plus
c'est le cas selon vous vous rejoignez
ses propos c'est vrai qu'on teste
beaucoup honte est beaucoup plus parce
que maintenant avec retard mais enfin
c'est tout de même arriver on dispose
des tests rapides antigénique honte est
beaucoup mais le quand on regarde le
pourcentage de le taux de positivité
tire le pourcentage de tests qui
reviennent positif il ne cesse
d'augmenter on a dépassé la d 13 % c'est
énorme
13% des personnes testées sont positives
car elles ne sont pas toutes malades
heureusement il y en a à peu près la
moitié qui sont malades
donc il va falloir suivre attentivement
de façon à dépister très vite les formes
graves nécessitant hospitalisation et
parmi ces dernières celles qui
nécessiterait
hymne à sion donc c'est pas le fait de
tester plus qui explique l'aggravation
des choses c'est le fait d'avoir une
épidémie qui est encore en phase de
croissance et au niveau des symptômes
est ce que vous observez une évolution
des changements alors je ne suis pas
cliniciens en est en activité mais ce
qui est rapporté c'est qu'il n'y a
absolument aucune différence de dans la
présentation clinique et dans la gravité
clinique de l'infection le virus n'a pas
changé contrairement à ce qui a été dit
parfois il mute oui il mute mais ces
bleus mans c'est à dire que les
changements du génome viral ne se
traduise pas par un changement de
comportement dans notamment dans la
gravité de l'infection elle est toujours
la même et elle est beaucoup plus forte
naturellement chez les personnes âgées
et chez les personnes qui sont atteintes
de différentes comorbidités alors plus
de 2000 personnes en réanimation un cif
qui vous inquiète étant donné nos
capacités bien sûr c'est cela qui est le
plus inquiétant
il faut espérer que le que les capacités
d'accueil de nos services de ranimation
ne sont pas débordés
sachant que les animateurs ont fait le
soin de ne pas sacrifier les autres
maladies nécessitant l'animation donc
s'ils auront en risque d'arriver
effectivement on a dit et vers la fin du
mois ou vers l'un ou plus tard vers la
mi novembre à une situation qui pourrait
être dramatique en ce sens qu on serait
obligé de bien de choisir quels sont les
malades à réanimer
et ce qui n'est malheureusement ne
pourront pas l'air merci ils lui sont
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes épidémiologistes
président du groupe kovy de l'académie
nationale de médecine